dig dig dig dig welcome back to the
Julian podcast it is about to get so
wild in here this episode is brought to
you by Squarespace if you're looking to
build a website or need a domain for
your business or online shop Squarespace
is the way to do it they offer many
different templates it's all very easy
and customizable and the best part in my
opinion is that they have 24/7 customer
support
so right now check out squarespace.com
for a free trial that's squ a re SP AC
com / Gemma Julian if you use our URL
which is linked below you get 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain check it out more on that later
also the skin guys get all your
information in a tidy format each
morning in an email so you don't have to
weed through all of the nonsense out
there you can get it all curated nicely
for you all the top news stories in the
world all the things that you really
need to know before going about your day
the skin takes care of it's completely
free you sign up at the skin calm / in
and Julian that's TAS ki mmm calm / Jena
Julian it's completely free just sign up
that's it also you entered to win a $250
Visa gift card when you do that you are
way too hyped up right now I drink two
coffees today what you drink the second
one one and a half
wait you drink the second one and a half
coffee where's that where's the rest of
it that's why you're so freaking and I'm
like dragon and you have the energy of a
thousand horses why because you found me
upstairs trying to teach peach how to
jump into the bathtub yes she likes it
she doesn't like she was crying I also
invented a game where I climb up the
stairs and she peeks her head through
all the railing holes trying to figure
out where I am and they pop up they
surprise me so stressful for her oh my
god it's my mom hold on yeah hello
no we're podcasting hi Debbie no no stay
yeah you say
okay okay cool I have leisure suits for
days I have leisure suits see thanks to
one of our sponsors that it's not on
this week but we're not getting dressed
yeah we're not getting dressed the rule
is no one gets dressed yeah good I would
hope so
me okay thank you impromptu guests love
you bye
so now we can write featuring Debbie in
the title I'm kiddin that's clickbait
this intermission has been brought to
you by my mother Wow
anyways I'm gonna try to jump into the
batter you're not because because
there's no room for error there you
there's no room for errors she jumps no
no no this isn't like practicing
backflips on a trampoline where there's
like it's bouncy and if you mess up it's
okay
that's like porcelain it's not porcelain
what is it's not it's like plastic it
looks like porcelain that's why I like
it so much because it's not like hard
and cold it's like a light plastic but
it still doing page
she's just home screaming really heavily
and intensely
you got it all riled up from the bathtub
game if she misses oh my god yeah too
much caffeine I'm not used to being on
this end of the equation I'm used to
being that
[Music]
that's not even English she understands
it she doesn't she's riding around
spastically humping her brother out of
stress I'm focused
you're not neither mom it's not my fault
I love that she just FaceTime you to
update you that we're only gonna wear
onesies and loungewear for this we get
dressed around each other anyways no we
don't but I like that she's setting the
rules because there's no room for
nonsense Oh turn tables yes I swear to
God if Kermit cries I know he's sleeping
outside tonight Kermit you're sleeping
outside he's been such a nasty boy it's
been unbelievable dude this morning okay
so that like last night mama got this
call well he didn't nor did I I was up
every like 30 minutes and yeah we
because marbles was like trying it
sounded like he's trying to get a
hairball out of his throat so that's
literally all night
it's better like three we woke up I woke
up like nine it was Saturday we was
playing from escape from tarkov
yeah and so I wake up and I get him some
medicine and I you know he goes back to
sleep and he finally stops coughing and
then it's Kermit's turn so he stands up
and like straddles my face while I'm
asleep like with his four legs and just
starts like loudly crying at him and he
hasn't stopped crying all day all day he
is the the most dramatic most sensitive
most miserable for no reason most
difficult and nasty boy I've ever met
and he just gets in these moods
sometimes where it is just amplified he
is the super nasty boy so wasn't me a
screenshot recently it like tweeted at
me of the video where I got him where
I'm like oh what's that noise he's
making and they were like little did
Jenna know he'd make that noise every
eight seconds for the next
years of his life like I feel like I've
been raising an infant child for this
many years and they haven't grown out of
the infant phase mm-hmm so when we have
an infant it's gonna be like oh we've
done this mm-hmm
except we just don't have to change your
little diaper
he likes diapers though look at him
looking at me god there's so much
emotion oh I still like one of my
favorite quotes about the dogs versus
children yeah is the one Philip DeFranco
was like you know that children are
different when up then dogs when you can
let your stupidest friend watch your dog
[Laughter]
that dingo in the baby
[Music]
wow I need more coffee I'm not used to
being out matched in the caffeine
Department this is bizarre I like your
black lipstick though thank you all
right so today we are gonna play guess
that vine or finish vanish that vine you
really only have like five on there you
don't even buy the premium one you have
ads on it I see the ad God so I spent
the last what hour-and-a-half going
through vines well this is what happened
we decided we're gonna do guest that
vine so or finish that vine rather and
finish that vine so I get on my computer
and start going through vines and
writing down vines and I hear in the
background other vines she was watching
vines - she was studying no it's not
fair i was doing what i would do anyways
but that's studying okay i was studying
so that means the expectations are even
higher for your performance on this test
stop doing that I can't my Aires is
getting to you
what's so proud of yourself isn't it a
good feeling
[Music]
how's it feel Julia
it feels weird I feel like I've lost
control of everything
I'm not that's you feel what you feel
right now that's control you're
controlling the pace of everyone that's
what I'm used to feeling oh wow this is
lovely well make sure you and sky I
think we should get started you have
your own sound board to celebrate your
little tiny victories when you guess or
you finish that vine it's guessing and
finishing and then at the end I have a
super vine that I made by combining a
bunch of vines into one sentence and I'm
gonna read it to you okay not to hype it
up or anything but it's pretty good I'm
ready okay we're gonna start off easy
actually it's not in any order some of
them are easy some of them are harder
some of them I just described what was
going on you have to describe the rest
of the vine okay look how serious you
just got I'm ready oh yeah if they ever
taught vine like as a as a major or even
a minor or even a class at a university
would you want to be the professor no
I'd want to be there to be the
know-it-all student you ever know it all
look on your face right now
yeah I mean it's totally possible to
trip me up I don't know every vine ever
distance but I'm pretty good you heard
it here she said it's impossible to trip
her up and she knows every vine in
existence marble everyone he's over
there standing very oddly okay country
boy I love you Wow okay one for one if
you had missed that one we would end at
the podcast yeah oh and so some of these
I also wrote out more than half and also
less than happening I kind of want to
gauge I might make it a little hard for
you okay and then if you need more I can
give you more okay give me your [ __ ]
money did she throws a giant baby doll
at her other belongings in it says Law &
Order SVU
well the baby doll was in giant it was
just like a Barbie but no it was like
the size of her
I don't know that slightly less tall
than she was a very small truck it's not
a handheld Barbie it was a absolutely
not no it's like the size of an American
Girl doll but like clearly lighter
already
mm-hmm you ready to [ __ ] die I know
this oh my god I know this well you got
this do it a hint yeah storms into room
with camera you ready to [ __ ] die
girl startled you can't kill me I'm a
bad day nice good recovery thank you
thank you thank you
alright so you ready to die yeah yeah
god I'm gonna describe this vine and you
have to just kind of explain what's
going on okay there's a basketball gym a
lot of people in the song we're breaking
free is playing what happens next
oh okay so it's a group of clearly like
students rehearsing for like a play or
something and they have their friend on
like a giant pulley harness they pull
him too hard and he goes right through
the ceiling tile and the ceiling tile
falls to the ground and smashes nice
thank you really descriptive all you had
to do is tell me they were in a
basketball gym yeah right yeah pretty
much it look what look that look it is
really hard look at all look at all
those chicken there you go good you're
good Chris is that a weed I'm really
calling the police then she types 9-1-1
into the microwave and it goes 9-1-1
what's your emergency and it plays the
x-files theme and he's dumbfounded that
she was able to call the police through
the microwave mm-hmm it wasn't a weed it
was a crayon how those chicken how those
chicken how those chicken strips [ __ ]
you chickens too
[ __ ] you chicken strips that wasn't a
popular vine on vine a lot of the ones
that are in compilations were not
popular man we've talked about that yeah
when there's too much drama at school
all you gotta do is walk away yeah yeah
yeah so proud of yourself it's a
confident I love it Pokemon okay there's
a couple there's two answers to this dj
khaled or there's also very [ __ ] good
good those are both of my answers that I
really get you Pikachu Pikachu
it's Clefairy [ __ ] mm-hmm
it's Pikachu no he just says it was
[Laughter]
[Music]
who's the hottest super driver you ever
had legendary vine we should we forgot
to tell you that if you didn't watch
mine this podcast is gonna oh yeah I
mean you can stay but don't blame us if
your name is jr. and you're really
handsome come on raise your hand don't
do the [ __ ] silent sound every time you
get it right so annoying hi welcome to
Chili's the caption of that was I'm
really proud of this one nice
alright I'm gonna make this one a little
hard I'm gonna just really very
beginning go off sis from the mana key
from the Manatee County Fair
I'm Linda Carson please
it's pants sorry oh no inside I'm a
failure
say hey vine hey vine sit 5 beat that
first little girl is so cute and the
second one's like meat she says it's
just like you do yeah you know what I'm
gonna say it I don't care that you broke
your elbow hey how much money do you
have like 69 cents you know what that
means
oh and then is that the one that where
the kids like I can't sleep because of
that video no oh that's a good at it no
I think you think you're Devery 100k hey
how much money you have it's the same
guy playing two characters hey how much
money you have like 69 cents you know
what that means that goes back to the
first I don't have enough money to buy
chicken nuggets nice good job is that
that's not dan curtain is it I actually
don't know whoever whoever whoever threw
that piece of paper your mom's a ho I'm
really saying one word like fine I
[Music]
thought you were BAE turns out you're
just them nice nick colletti
[Laughter]
what I smell like beef
I smell like beef I smell like beef I
smell like beef
I smell like leave this [ __ ] empty yay
miss Keesha oh my [ __ ] guys she
[ __ ] dead ain't got no sleep cuz of
y'all y'all not gonna see cuz of me
she's like slapping like two pans
together sleep cuz y'all y'all not go
getting asleep cuz it be that was from
Bad Girls Club right I've never seen
that show wasn't is that what the
finders from yeah the the show is Bad
Girls Club
cuz I know her but I've never watched
that show or her okay this one's gonna
be kind of difficult to act out sorry
mmm-hmm there are some great edits of
that by the way so that wasn't an actual
vine that was just a clip of a show -
this is one where they act out both
parts hey Darren do you know where we're
going hey Daria sup [ __ ] I think the
caption with that was something like why
do girls love when guys like our total
[ __ ] to them or something like that
[Laughter]
Zak stop you're gonna get in trouble
Zak stop what's happening in this part
what's happening them okay clearly they
filmed it in Reverse no no describe the
vine and then we'll analyze okay so it's
a guy wearing jeans open-toed sandals a
white shirt a black beanie I think and
he's just like walking around the street
taking his foot up really high like this
they're going Zak stop you're gonna get
in trouble Zak stop and then it clips to
a police scene of him against a fence
like getting handcuffed but it's like an
actual found footage of someone filming
in
so you said they feel I think yes all
the arrests yeah then they just had
their friend dress up like that and
walking around kicking there's like four
cop cars yeah uh does it feel good
what ah no I love I love you [ __ ]
I never gonna stop loving you [ __ ] good
I thought you were doing peanut butter
baby
ah peanut butter baby ah good to to buzz
chillin in a hot tub five feet apart cuz
they're not gay that's Anthony Padilla
so no head what happens next
he throws his phone and then he jumps on
his skateboard and it snaps in half
thank you
slow down grab your Bible obviously no
one you have to split that grab your
breath your Bible pray like you're
trying to make your soul revival just
this little girl in a gymnasium like a
high school gymnasium and she's just
like taking it fully seriously and
singing this version of it Wow
damn that's the first thing you like to
absolutely didn't get did for her pray
like you're trying to make your soul
revival it's cold outside
I'm still looking like her like a ho
because the ho never gets cold
that's cardi B yeah mmm-hmm oh man my
god I love Chipotle Chipotle is my life
this is bad and I can say one word what
that [ __ ] is up Kyle
no step the [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] is up
Kyle nice this sounds good I'm just
gonna read it my favorite fall vegetable
is a sweet potato I think it was like a
promotion to get people to eat more
vegetables sweet potato
she was real extra about it yeah I mean
me mom's car Boom Room get out me car oh
is that right yeah that's right it's
terrifying how could you why is it
terrifying it is Wednesday my dudes what
did I do that was it okay I sustained
the air damage from it but is worth it
okay stop is that it yeah you got to
tell me if I get them right I'm you've
gotten every single one right except for
slow down grab your Bible pray thank you
thank you so revival praise the Lord
you can't sit with us actually Megan I
can't sit anywhere
I had hemorrhoids stated students to do
oh you acted that one out
that was me out nice job thank you
what why do you laugh it's impressive
when do I need help no I don't know the
answer to that question specifically the
power of Christ compels a beautiful
basset hound yeah it's like what we do
to our dogs pretty much should rile them
up with nonsense I want a church girl
they go to church and read her Bible
unless it was Nicoletti in which case it
was I want a Jewish girl that go to
Temple and reader Torah that was a that
was an IB vine right right I don't know
why B vine me they would tag IB idea by
and then tag the person looks like a
good good talk
[ __ ] if you want a burger eat a burger
a [ __ ] if you want a friend track eat a
french ride nice those young puppy [ __ ]
if you what [ __ ] if you wanna website
get a website using Squarespace the best
website making domain ever in the [ __ ]
walk out that door
speaking of Willian Squarespace is such
a great way to build a website make a
blog about all your favorite vines or
you want to make a really really angry
opinion piece about our podcast
Squarespace is a way to do it if you
have a business if you have an online
shop or you just want to create a
website for fun Squarespace has all the
different capabilities that make it easy
for you to just create a website I'm
angry there's no coding skills involved
for you they make it user friendly
there's a built-in RSS feed that lets
you publish to Apple podcasts and other
subscription services while your web
sites can you not do that
please can help listeners find archived
episodes we currently use Squarespace
for our website is very very easy and it
does the job at the end of the day you
want a website that is readable and easy
and looks the way you want it and
functions well and Squarespace hits all
of those boxes even if you have no idea
where to start and you just want to
build a website they have 24/7
award-winning customer support and make
it easy to learn all you need to know
about building website with Squarespace
the future is coming make it brighter
with Squarespace and make your mark on
the internet with your website using
Squarespace
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial or go to squarespace.com slash
Jenna Julianne to save 10% on your first
purchase of a website or domain and then
tweet us your website a lot of you have
done that and it's really cool because
we get to check out your websites after
you've made them and then sign up for
the skin when you want to learn all of
the top news stories that are happening
in the world just so you're educated
whether it's good or bad like for
instance the whole fire that ravaged
North in Southern California last week
and the week before you need to be in
the know about all these things so when
you go about your day you're
knowledgeable and you have all the tools
to equip yourself to be successful and
to not look stupid in front of other
people you need to know things and this
kit makes it easy to know things they
put all the top news stories in your
inbox and one simple email every single
morning is completely free and they're
very reliable
just like my sponsor segways you know
they're gonna be there every day
check your inbox and there it is just
waiting for you while you're brushing
your teeth or while you're skipping
brushing your teeth because you just
don't want to brush your teeth that day
you're reading the skin I'm learning
about what you need to know so check it
out right now go to this skin calm
that's th es ki mmm calm / - Jenna
Julianne enter your email click and
subscribe that's literally it it's free
just check it out if you if you would
like to I suggested it supports the
podcast give it a shot also by doing
that you are in the running for a $250
Visa gift card which they are giving
away Kermit don't step on the keyboard
don't
thank you sponsors to check out the skin
check out Squarespace great services
he's too much who him
you too much alright well we're a little
over halfway done yeah how are you
feeling pretty good
have I missed anything you think I'm
gonna hit or that you're worried I won't
hit what do you mean I don't know
there's a couple legendary ones that I
haven't got to yet okay I'm excited
mmm-hmm
mother trucker that hurt like a biscuit
on his thick [ __ ] I don't know what he
says
mother trucker dude that hurt like a but
she got ass dead she gonna stick it out
of him no four out of five same thing
thanks good job thank you I don't know
how to read this one though but I'll
just read it like in normal and you have
to guess it welcome to my kitchen
we have bananas and avocados making fun
of the way that indie singers sound
mm-hmm that's a good one it's a good
bite sit speak that's a small little dog
that someone dubbed over it goes sit
speak dog just go
when I hear you you want to keep doing
this but when you come around you never
want to post up as a little girl on your
bike when you come around you never try
to post up put that candy back first of
all you said something like are you
trying to buy you all that she throws it
and then he goes oh trauma [ __ ] put
that candy back I'm not buying you all
that mess yeah try me [ __ ] like like
just dissect that vine a little bit if
that's a kid who's filming right while
they're holding candy they get told that
authority figure is employee of the
store maybe I might like I don't know I
just know too many sing it sing the
whole thing Wow okay this is this is a
legendary one that you know but I want
to see if you can get it exactly right
okay okay cuz it's you know there's an
order to it
happy chrimbus man comes that beat
Chrysler it's really hard I know I don't
that's right it's kind of unfair yeah
that was it
it goes happy chrimbus is crimine no is
Chrisman Mary crisis Mary Chrysler sorry
yeah well you know if you're gonna be a
vine professor you need to know oh and
Alex and I are both in that fine um
Jared could you um Jerry could you
please I don't know um Jerry could you
please read number 23 for the class no I
can't
hey guys I'm Darrin in nineteen I've
never [ __ ] learned how to read right
[Laughter]
all right I'm gonna read this and sort
of describe it and you have to finish it
good
ha ha ha ha hey what's up peace sign
it's a very big cuz there's probably a
lot of mines that start like that yeah
ha ha hey what's that okay anymore I
need more information
it's so basically um take sunglasses off
no I put a hook to make a long story
short I put a whole bag of jelly beans
up my ass no no Kay cuz I was like
there's no sunglasses in that line so
basically um take something glasses oh
then he gets punched in the face and he
goes I can't believe you've done this
how did you get that nobody knows the
first half of that vine yes I do yep no
you you do yes yeah that was it okay
what I was thinking is it's can't
believe you've done this ladies and
gentlemen welcome to
[Applause]
that's like the same as RadioShack oh do
you have the ham horn on there because
we could recreate the whole vibe no boo
there's one thing worse than a rapist
rips off thing a child no nice good good
good good good thank you
how do you keep your pants up belt nice
what is that can you describe that vine
yeah it's just that weird guy that would
go backstage and interview people in
like one sentence how do you keep your
pants up that zooms in don't all right
so this is okay I'm gonna give you very
little info for this okay it's a video
that starts of the container of hummus
okay oh my god Sabra has all your basic
nutrition needs like zero trans fat and
only God cholesterol good really good
thank you
this [ __ ] empty eat nope
this [ __ ] called me ugly
she said under all I said [ __ ] where
she said under all that makeup I said
[ __ ] where okay so this is a vine where
the guy who's making the vine is holding
a microphone up to his mouth and in the
top right hand corner is a picture of
another man you are my dad you're my dad
boogie woogie woogie well done perfect I
love that vine I love all of his lines
she she what'd she do just say what fake
brick did what are my tweets she was a d
okay that was that was perfect
what shirt is he wearing in that vine
it's a purple is it a purple Lakers
shirt
God what that is so weird that they know
what five like seven million times he's
wearing a purple Lakers shoes she's
wearing like a Santa hat like a red
sports bra or something you know what
kind of bra she's wearing yeah oh my god
cuz she's sitting to his right okay I'm
gonna destroy his left butt stage right
I I'm gonna describe this one this is a
this is a visual vine there's no audio
really but it is the hilarious fine
nonetheless okay so you're in the
perspective of someone sitting on a bus
mm-hmm and the girls arguing with no one
and then she goes no that is good is it
the one with no no you can't just list
all the bus lines thank you that is a
freaky Padma she's like freaking out
okay so you're in the perspective of
somebody sitting on the left side of the
aisle camera turns to the right it's a
woman in a orange top okay so he goes
like this or her hand and touches it and
she just goes like this say there's
another one where the kid goes excuse my
French food shut the [ __ ] up it's also a
bus fine yeah there's another bus fine
where this girl gets a Apple to the head
she like an Apple gets thrown at her so
she throws it back and then this like
little kid picks up and just Chuck's it
it's like explodes on her head okay so
the last one I wrote is weird the last
one already I'm sorry this was a lot of
work okay
we belong together thank you okay um hey
I really need to say something I don't
know keep going I mean I really knew say
something that's Lennar that was Lennar
that was the sibling that what is the
title was like sibling always need to
tell you the dumbest [ __ ] yeah round of
applause thank you
I'm proud but also concerned at how will
he know something I'm not concerned I
actually want to read you a sentence
that actually yeah I combined a bunch of
lines into one sentence okay okay so I
have to get them all yeah all right I'm
ready
do I have to read them all in the voice
no okay
I want a country boy is that a weed that
smells like beef stop I could have
walked away from Chili's okay I want a
country boy wait what I don't understand
what you want me to do just pick out
every single vine that's in there it's
like a crossword puzzle the words I
wanna is I want a church good okay
that's what I - Chris is that a weed it
smells like beef stop I could've dropped
my croissant just walked away yeah yay
from hi welcome to Chili's you got him
dude well then okay brain-busters I
don't have any more brain-busters bust
me butts - you got any more no I like
sat through vines for a long time and
tried to write every single one down
that I think would be good this game is
fun I want to play it forever
yeah I would be fun if we had an
infinite amount of line quizzes maybe I
can work on some more vine quizzes if we
could do part two I'm really good at
vines or we could create a website of
vine quizzes
no it's like really fun it's fun I also
want to play though - how do we like pay
someone to make us a bunch of behind
quizzes I don't know I don't know I mean
that could be good because it is it is
fun but it is hard - I don't need any
visuals I don't need any sounds either
just like somebody telling literally a
third of the vines you guess today you
guess with one word yeah
like how I don't know except you did get
the hi are you Javier wrong yes sorry hi
in it you bring that back oh yeah I
bested you on that one
Julian called Chris live on stream to
confirm that he
in fact say hi sorry what else what else
are friends for also what else our
phones for also what else our vines for
that's how Sony dito well I hope you
guys enjoyed me reading one word at a
time to Jenna guessing an entire vine
from that one word I'm as impressed as
if I was in a pageant that's what that's
what my talent portion would be like I
can guess any vine ever any vine well
not any vine ever it's way too hard but
any funny vine that was mildly popular I
can yes yeah I mean that was pretty good
although I think that that was
relatively easy like I could have if I
really dug for a while I could have
found some nuggets that might have been
yeah you can stop me I can stomp you did
yeah but I also you know I wanted to
make it like an intro one in case we did
more that we could get harder and harder
mm-hm why you smiling like that he is
such a know-it-all smile
well we will be back after Thanksgiving
I hope everybody has a wonderful
Thanksgiving week we are very thankful
for one more amazing year on the podcast
with you guys and we're gonna take next
week off to eat full seafood well next
week we're not gonna be eating food but
this week we are and that's when we
would record so hopefully you guys have
a good food every week how facts amazing
we'll be back following me we're
skipping one week so next Monday go
watch some vines or something educate
yourselves but yeah I will see you guys
on the next one thank you for watching
and vine
[Music]